and here we go
so welcome everyone to our expert
am i on the wrong presentation here
excuse me this is my mistake
matt and i were just discussing things
like power outages and
okay
and i apologize for that glitch
much better
take two
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn i want to
welcome everyone to our
digital marketing master class a
on link building for successful digital
marketing campaigns with
matt bailey the founder and president of
sitelogic marketing and
a member of our digital marketing
faculty at simplylearn
and
just a note about how to use the webex
controls
you can
put questions for matt into the q and a
panel
at any time
we'll cue those up for him
toward the end of the session
you also have a chat function
and
sorry
we're also going to be pulling you
several times during the webinar for
your
information and insights
and
let's get this first poll started
okay
and basically
two quick questions one is how much work
experience do you have
are you still in school or
have you been working in industry
for some time this is not specific to
technology or digital marketing just how
much work experience do you have in
general
and secondly we're checking in with
people on how how they're doing during
the pandemic so
with that said let me show you what the
result is
i had mentioned to matt before the
session started that we had a power
outage
locally here and my system is running
sluggishly
so hopefully it'll catch up
let's show the poll results
so a little over a third of the audience
has more than 10 years of experience
matt um
and about a quarter are folks who are
still in school so it's distributed
among lots of different levels
and with that said i'm going to
introduce you
president of sitelogic
a digital marketing instructor for the
direct marketing association
and an instructor for the online
marketing certified professional program
and you've also written several books
including internet marketing an hour a
day
wired to be loud and teach an old dog
new tricks it's a great title
so welcome matt thank you for being here
and i am going to um transfer
control to you
all right thank you stuart
and a moment all right
as i said
it's
sluggish system
yeah the the shear button is uh
yeah you should have it now there we go
all right
thank you stuart i appreciate the
handoff here and also appreciate the
opportunity to present once again for
simply learn
and let me
get all of this up and running and make
sure whoops
all right stuart is everything up and
running can you see the screen and
everything
yes sir
all right i always need to make sure of
that anymore um
even though we're you know from the work
from home and and all these online
things you still can't take anything for
granted
you still need to make sure everything
is working but thank you so much for
joining me today about link building now
i'm going to cover a number of areas
about link building for today's webinar
links why they're so important for seo
links and why and how they build
credibility
how to measure link quality
looking at link placement link
measurement
link management and then i'm going to
end with seven ways to build links so
today it's all about link building and
that's probably why so many of you are
here and ready to
listen for this but before i start i
would like to ask you let's do another
poll
i would like to know
of the five areas that i've listed
which is your least favorite part of seo
and which is your favorite part of seo
so stuart if you could put that poll up
there there we go
i would love to know before we start
those of you that are in seo that are
doing it or learning it
what's your least favorite and what is
your favorite
i may have accidentally stopped at the
poll
okay
hold on a second
there we go i've restarted it
get that going here
i apologize for that glitch that's okay
sluggish system i thought i hadn't hit a
button and i hit it twice
right quite all right
all right yes please answer now uh your
least favorite part of seo and your
favorite part of seo being that this is
a link building webinar i'm kind of
curious where you stand and also if it
lines up with another recent poll that
was done asking people about their least
favorite and their favorite parts of seo
all righty not seeing
i'm getting the poll that's what it is
i'm getting the pull here so
uh yeah okay
here we go
here's the results of our informal poll
and we've got quite a few people on
today's webinar so i think we're going
to have a good good mix
oh wow that's a surprise well maybe not
maybe not if you're seeing the results
here the programming and the technical
part of seo is the least favorite by far
wow
almost half of you have that down as
your least favorite and i'm not
surprised that um now let me see your
favorite part keyword research i have to
say that is my favorite part as well is
the keyword research because i learn so
much about audience and what they want
and the words they use
um now 16 was link building was the
second least favorite activity uh but
yeah i can't fault you on the
programming and technical side uh that
is one of the most difficult parts of
seo so i can't fault you with that and
that is a great great response so thank
you for your input on that
all right well i asked that because
search engine land did the same poll
recently asking people what is your
least favorite part of seo and by far
link building was the number one
least favorite activity
some of the quotes that people gave were
just amazing
someone said that
doing backlinks building backlinks is
like a vampire sucking your soul for a
little bit of return
uh others said it was time consuming too
much work
pointless not rewarding and also
the work of having to clean up other
people's mistakes
especially when it's cleaning up bad
links from a previous agency or previous
seo who really didn't know or didn't
care
and they used
really bad methods of building links
that
worked against the website and now
someone has to clean it up
so that was a great
interesting comparison of our poll and
the recent poll by search engine land
and i understand
the concept i understand why people find
these things and i understand the
language
working in an agency for years managing
seo managing seo departments and
managing agencies
link building was of the seos that i
that worked for me it was one of the
least favorite
and i find it's because there was a lack
of
a framework of how are we going to
approach this step one step two step
three
rather it was more of
just go find links
but i found when we instituted a
framework and a process of building
links it actually then gave people a
direct
path
to what they could do and the activities
they could focus on to build links and i
was happy to say we
had a great great time and great results
in building links because we followed
that path now first
links are
vitally important to search engine
optimization
i like to break down search engine
optimization into three primary areas
and that is the content that's on the
page
the links
that are both internal and external
and the structure the programming the
architecture how the website is built
all three of these are vitally important
the structure the architecture
allows the search engine spider to come
in and see the content that's there
it also utilizes the internal linking
structure to find all of the pages
now also it's the content that makes
people link to your website
they don't link to you unless your
content is great unless there's
something that they like or want to
recommend
and so those incoming links
are a direct result of the content and
so all these three things have to work
together in order to get rankings in the
search engines
now here's a couple of facts
about links and we have to think about
this
when we approach even just the subject
of building links in seo
number one
is that links imitate human judgment
you see
we can and very early websites and early
algorithms and search engines were based
on the content of the page
and that's what led to
keyword density and repeating keywords
100 times on the page because if i had
this the right keyword and i used it
more than my competitor then i'd be more
relevant
the problem was it was only one
dimension
of
judgment
and that was how many times i had the
key word on the page
or
to take it into more of the offline
world it was what i said about myself
what lynx added as a different dimension
was external validation
external judgment as to the value of a
website
and so links are critical and this is
how google changed the game with search
engines
is that they brought in that external
management that external judgment of is
this a good site is this a credible
website
does it have expertise
and so by asking those external
questions
it helped to then judge if this is an
authoritative website and one that
should be ranked highly
you see all the algorithm is attempting
to do
is mimic how we make decisions
you see we may have a group of friends
that help influence our choices and
influence the decisions that we make
however that group of friends may not
have credibility when it comes to
medical decisions or a medical diagnosis
they may have our influence but not in
that area
in the area of medical knowledge we
would consult an expert we want someone
who has education we want someone who is
knowledgeable and so
depending upon the question
different people or different websites
are going to have different levels of
influence and credibility
and that's what a search engine
algorithm is attempting to unravel is
what are the factors that we use
personally
to make decisions
and how do we then
make those human factors mathematical
algorithms to determine the same thing
it comes down to trust
who do you trust
and so typically we have a group of
people that we trust friends relatives
those that are close to us and we trust
what they say
but then also
whenever if those of you that are still
students when you write a paper
you need to cite a source
where did you get this data where did
you get this information and so you have
to cite that information and in doing so
what you're saying is
as i developed this content i found
information here and i am giving a
citation to them because that was a
trusted source of information
well also we look for experts we look
for authorities people with proven
expertise that they publish they are
recognized experts and we can utilize
them
also
validation and this is where reviews
recommendations third-party opinions are
important to helping us understand what
were the experiences of other people
what did they see what did they
experience
and now how does that help me make a
better judgment
and finally we look for word of mouth
from our friends from other people a
great example is
i was talking to someone about
podcasting and how do you find new
podcasts
and i'm trying to find to see if there's
any research here but i think most
people will subscribe to a podcast from
word of mouth
rather than going and searching for a
podcast on marketing or on seo there's
going to be thousands of them how do you
know which one's any good and you don't
have time to listen to hundreds of
podcasts to see which one is you're
going to like
rather
we rely on word of mouth so like i said
i think that may be a research project
that i'll do in the future if i can't
find it
but that's what google's pagerank
algorithm was all based on
it was
replicating
our human assessment of credibility
of authority
and popularity
it was looking for the sites that were
cited the most often
and that also influenced other websites
and influencing how pages link together
and that's what made google such a game
changer early in the 2000s
is because they relied on external
factors
very similar to how we rely on these
same factors
to make decisions
now
link fact number two
a quality link
beats quantity
all of the time
now you may receive offers for hundreds
or thousands of links but ultimately
what it comes down to is what one
quality link one high quality link
can beat millions of low quality links
it's not a game about getting the most
links
it's about getting
the best links
that's what it's all about and so when
we approach link building many times i
think seos have in mind i've got to get
a dozen links or i've got to get you
know i've got to get 20 links now what
you need
is the best link and we need to go
figure out what that best link is going
to do
i've seen it many times on websites
where
we'll find a link opportunity and once
that link is in place
it immediately impacts the rankings just
that one
link
and so we need to focus on
quality and by quality i'm looking at
where am i going to get that link from i
need to find a quality link source
so when we look at link quality you can
have a website here and and they can
have
you know maybe
you know 200 other websites linking to
them
but if you have another website and you
have only one website linking to them
and but here's where the linking and
here's where google changed it
it's
who is linking
to the pages that are linking to you
it's a step back
and so if i've got a great site here
linking to this website we'll call this
website a
there's no one linking
to that website
and so this website that is giving me
this link does not have a lot of
credibility it doesn't have a lot of
authority
but yet if i've got links over here
we'll call this website b
and not only do they have direct links
coming from other websites we need to
look at
who is linking to these other websites
because if these are quality
websites
what they're going to do is create
quality here
and then it's going to create quality
for us
and so it's not just who's linking to
you it's who's linking to those sites
that make them a high quality link
partner that's what we're developing
here
now here's a great example and and this
you may see you know this is not direct
link building but what this is is a
great example of how to use
outbound linking
to develop inbound
linking
which increases rankings
now this was an article done by kinsta
you can see it here and they created an
article called the 13 best google
analytics alternatives all right
now i want you to see what they did they
started first of all with original
content
why is this important
why should you consider alternatives
and what are the three
main reasons and then yeah that's below
the fold here
so they added original content in a
great article about why should you
consider using something other than
google analytics
they also linked externally to other
places such as how to use google
analytics
uh
google docs google search console uh
youtube and so and also privacy google's
privacy policy so they
linked to a lot of external sources as
they pulled together this article
then
they started with the alternatives and
they linked to each
each google
competitor and you can see here so we
start with stack counter they've got a
screen grab of the website a direct link
to the website
a direct quote pulled from the website
and
just a paragraph of content and then
they pulled the pricing diagram
so in reality when they started creating
the analytics alternatives part of this
article
the vast majority of it was screenshots
and quotes
pooled and developed as an article
now what's interesting is if you go to
google right now and you search for
google analytics alternatives you're
going to find this article ranking
higher than any of the websites that
they cite as examples or alternatives
that's because they pulled together
original content
curated content from all these other
websites
developed an original
information and got it out there and
then because they're ranking number one
people start linking to this article
as a source of trusted information
and the reason why is because they are
in the ranking and because they got the
ranking people start linking to them and
as they gain more linking links they're
moving up in the the search engine as
well and then also some of these sites
went ahead and linked to the article as
well
because of what was said about them
so link building isn't always about
going and asking someone
to get a link on their site
sometimes it's creating your own link
opportunities through original content
development and
a smart way of putting together a
comparison
and showing information where you're
educating your audience
now i will say this avoid the following
about link building i i i'm not sure
what level sometimes i have to put
information out here but i want to be
sure this is clear
be warned when people approach you about
link exchanges
put your link and you add a link and
let's link to each other or add your
link to our page of a hundred other
links avoid that
avoid anything that is automated
link building programs
automated link building requests
anytime you pay for a link building
service
chances are it is automated and i could
show you examples of emails that i have
that are obviously automated
because
the the
fonts are different the text is
different they
misalign things they grabbed database
information that doesn't fit
it's obvious it's an automated link
request and it makes your brand look
terrible
guest blogging is up in the air
a lot of people recommend it and a lot
of people don't so
that's got an asterisk here because
that's up to you to see if it might work
for you
and there are better opportunities than
others but i would say that guest
blogging is kind of a very gray area it
depends on how it's done
and do your research before you embark
on that because that can be an area that
might work against you it could work for
you
but it's going to depend on
who you work with and how that happens
also avoid buying any links with a
nofollow google has said if they find
you buying links that have a no follow
attribute you will get penalized for
that
and of course anyone who offers you
hundreds or thousands of links to to
your site just avoid that it's not a
good idea as i said it's about quality
it's about getting one link
one link that can turn everything around
and make a huge impact in your site
don't think about quantity don't think
about hundreds or thousands
because then it might lead to bad
decisions
now if i'm getting a link on someone
else's site the one place i want that
link to be is in the editorial content
all right i don't want my link to show
up in their footer i don't want it to be
in other places because
when google is assessing pages the
the highest most important content is in
that editorial block that means that
someone
curated the information
organized it wrote it and it went
through an approval process before it
was published
and so if i can get that link into the
story or into the content
just like the article that i showed you
a few slides back that was full of links
going to other places going to resources
citing information
that's the most valuable place to get
the link not on a link page not on uh
you know a link partner page but
actually in
the content
that's where it's most valuable
now when i measure a link
when i'm measuring a link i look for
four things
number one i look for branding that if
my name shows up on another website i
want to look at how prominent is that
website
how prominent is the the link
and what's the estimated traffic for
that site or that page how many people
are are going there
that's what i want to look at and then i
want to know
is it the url
that they're linking to
or are they using anchor text
and if they're using anchor text are
they using my business name
or
are they using
a keyword
like the service
or product
that's what i want to know is what kind
of branding so if even if people don't
click on the link
what information are they getting what
information can they see
and even if my business name shows up on
this website how prominent is it and
what's the value of just simply having
my name there as part of the content
that people can see
next i'm interested in the rankings how
can this link affect my rankings there's
a number of programs out there that can
show you the value of getting a link on
another website
i like this example here this is uh from
a company called link decks
and not only so for example here there
is a link from oops let me get back on
that
there is a link from the national
institutes of health
and that link is going to
the mayo clinic here
now not only is this a great domain
meaning a high value high quality domain
it also is a relevant domain see there's
two things we need to think about when
we get that link
number one is the quality
of the domain that's linking to us
is it a high value high quality domain
you see it can be a high value high
quality domain
but not
relevant
keyword wise
and that's what the second factor would
be
is it related is that domain related to
my industry
and so that's where this tool link decks
shows me that for example here is a high
quality domain
but it does not have the keyword
relevance and so it's it fits one of the
factors of
which is quality
but is not as relevant same thing down
here the peta.org
for this website is a high quality a
good influential domain but it has very
little keyword relevance
and so it has to have those two factors
in order to have an impact on your
rankings
just having a quality domain will still
increase your rankings
but having a quality domain
in your industry with high keyword
relevance it increases it even more
now the next thing is i can measure link
building efforts through visits i can
look at my analytics and i can see
how this affects
my my business now what i'm looking for
here is referral
anytime you get a link on another
website and people follow that link
that is classified under referral that
that website referred visitors to us
and so that's what we're looking at so
in this column i can see a direct result
of link traffic
people clicking on my link and coming to
the site and i can see
and if you've got
value and value calculation and values
in your goals
then you can see not only how many
visits you get but you can also see the
conversion rate the number of
conversions and how much that's worth
and so you can directly measure the
amount of visits that are generated
now next is
i can look specifically and see which
sources
so i can look and see which sources
which link sources are sending visitors
so for this example i can see two
specific link sources that are sending
visits
and they're sending sales
and so that's i can see now a direct
business objective
achieved from link building not just for
building rankings but now i'm generating
hundreds of visitors from these links
that are buying things
and so now i can see the link is not
just an opportunity to raise rankings
but it increases my sales it increases
my goals it increases my conversion rate
and that is what i'm looking for because
that i can immediately show results of
what i've done
you can get reports where you can see
all of the incoming links and what they
have provided and one thing to look out
for though are bot visits and i've got
that labeled here this bot traffic and
then bot traffic here and how you can
spot those is they behave very different
because they're bots they're not humans
for example
this one
has a zero percent bounce rate
and that's because they request two
pages
by requesting two pages instead of one
they create a zero percent bounce rate
that might look good
but then we can see here
that the average session duration is
less than four seconds
and
no sales no conversions no money
now the other side of this
is this first one
99 bounce rate one page session view
and no time on site and again
zero
in conversion rate and transactions
that's how you spot bots they don't act
like humans and when you have that many
bot visits and you have that clear of
bounce rates pages session duration
you can see it doesn't look like
anything else
it looks very different and so that will
help you recognize any bot traffic
and the reason why we look for that
is many times people will sell you link
partners
that will sell you links and these links
will provide traffic
and if you're not careful you might buy
that that hey of course i want links
that'll send traffic
the problem is the traffic that they
send is software created bots
and you'll look at your analytics and
say hey that that cr that sent a lot of
visits
but if you look deeper into it you'll
see that all those visits are bots and
that's what you bought is
software bots coming and looking at
pages
all right
i would like to add this um
one of the seo tools that i absolutely
love and they've got a relationship with
simply learn as well in some of the
simply learned classes you can get a
free trial and then also uh they offered
a free trial for everyone on this
webinar as well uh it is se ranking and
this is an seo tool that will track your
backlinks and so i just put the link
into the chat if you want a 45 day free
trial to seo rankings seo tools
grab it get on it i don't know how you
know you can get on here um previously
this was only available to uh simply
learn students if you were enrolled uh
but now for anyone on the webinar we can
get that as well now here's why i love
that software
number one it allows me to see who's
linking to me
i can track how many links and how many
domains
so here i can see that i have over a
thousand domains linking to my site um
and i have a domain trust of 87. now
this is on a scale of 100 and
0 to 100
and what they're trying to do with the
domain trust
is
really use the same factors that they
think
google is using
and then bring them down and they create
their own measurement of a domain trust
all right and so you can get a sense of
your total referring domains and why
they report domains as well as the
number of links is because you can have
four or five links from one domain so it
helps break it up
i can also see
what links are follow and what links are
nofollow i can see how many are from dot
com sites how many are from
dotnet.org.edu
and and more uh but here i've got a
total of uh almost 4 000 backlinks from
over 1 000 websites uh a good thing too
i can see links that go to the home page
and links that go to the inside pages
here's why that's important
because if it only goes to the home page
then my home page will have the highest
level of credibility and authority
the more links that go to internal pages
it increases
their relevance their authority their
credibility so not only does it raise
the domain trust of my domain it raises
the page trust of each individual
page when i get links deeper into the
site
now as you can see here
um
one thing that i'm looking at is the
domain trust of the sites that are
linking to me
and you can see here two websites that
have a 100 domain trust wikipedia and
linkedin
those are two
high-value properties and then we can
see you know from then on there it's in
the 90s
but those are high value domains and
getting a link on a high value domain
automatically increases your credibility
and increases what happens
so this is why i love this
get your free trial at sc ranking
do the backlink checker
and now you can also get an seo audit
you can do keyword research but this
backlink checker
this will show you what you're doing and
i'm also going to show you how you can
use it to find what your competitors are
doing and that would help you with your
link building
all right let's take another poll here
some of you may be already trying to get
that trial but let's take a second here
and uh let's uh i'd like to know what
digital marketing skills you're most
interested in learning
all right and we'll bring that up in
just a second here
and that should be launched
all right pulls up so please let us know
what you're interested in learning
i'll close it in about three seconds
and here's the result
all right
content marketing social media
analytics seo
seo's at the top love it that's my
background seo so i can't
can't argue with that i love it but uh
yeah seo social
good good and right away all right
absolutely that's great
thank you for your input on that
now i'm gonna get seven ways to build
links and then we'll take questions
all right number one way to build links
first thing to do is to go search for
your business name
search for your business name on every
search engine because they might give
different results um but number one
thing is to verify what is the the napu
and that is verify that your business
name
your address
your phone number and your url
are exactly the same
everywhere
i cannot stress the importance of this
so your business name so it might be
like the name and maybe it's llc
uh or something like that if on some
websites you have the llc and other
websites you don't
that might cause
you know we're looking at search engines
here they're they're machines not humans
so we need to make sure it's absolutely
clear
same thing with your address the format
of the address should be exactly the
same
your phone number and the format of the
phone number and of course your url are
you using www or are you not using www
are you linking with https or just http
uh
you know
make sure everything come up with one
standardized
listing
that lists all of these elements and
then
look everywhere that your webs that your
business is listed
and ensure now you may have to log in
create an account you may have to ask
the administrator to amend things but
this is the first level is ensuring that
all this information is correct and in
one format
if it you don't want to see variations
on this
second thing
who mentions you
as you're searching for your business
look and see who might be mentioning you
but they don't include a link
and so this is the next level
not only make sure that your business
information is the same but who
who's talking about you and this is a
great way to approach because they've
already mentioned you they've already
included you on a webpage or on their
website well now you just need to find
who's the right person fill out the
contact form and by the way when you do
this whenever you contact anybody
about linking to your site
number one
be polite
be
nice
give them as much help and information
as you can because here's the rule they
don't have to do anything
nobody has to give you a link
no one is under any obligation to give
you a link
so the best way to do this is to be nice
it's to ask nicely and make it as easy
as possible um
and so be sure to
think about your approach
when getting those backlinks so second
thing look for anyone that mentions you
without a link and ask them to link
third thing
start with internet directories yeah
they're still around and yes i still
tell people to get into those internet
directories especially for a new website
this is important it you need to build
this basis of links
so look for internet directories look
for business directories
also if you are part of an association
or an industry and there are pages where
there's lists of businesses anywhere
that you can get in where it's an
industry an association
a business anything like that or an
internet directory
go ahead and apply get your listing in
there and this is where also knowing
your name address phone number business
name url
remember it's got to be the same
everywhere so this is your next step to
link building
well now it's going to get harder and
this is where i use se ranking and
here's an example we were
looking at
one of our sites here
and we looked at competitor backlinks
and one of the things we found and and
this this is always you know one of
those things that you see in the
backlinks and it might be depressing
that they have nbc news
vice
bold cbs
so obviously they have gotten backlinks
from very very important media sites
and we look to see and it was an
interview and the interview got picked
up well we can't compete with that
however what we did see is that they had
a couple of links on reddit which is a
social site
and in sc ranking it will show you that
there are two backlinks you click on
this and it will show you where those
links are
it'll show you the subreddit where the
links are
it will show you the domain trust look
at that a reddit domain is is a 97. uh
the page trust is a 28 that's cool uh
and it will show you the anchor text and
the url of where it's linking to your
competitor
so what this enabled for us
uh stuart i don't know if you can uh
mute some of the other there's a i think
a couple microphones on here
so what's happening here
is i can go and look at competitor
websites
see who's linking to them
where those links are
and what this directed us to
was to
go to reddit in that same subreddit and
find a way that we can mention
our client
mention what they offer and how then now
we'll get links from them so that's what
we're trying to do when we can use
competitor backlink reports
in order to target very specific
destinations
all right next thing
and this was also from the competitive
report
stuart i don't know if you can if you're
hearing this as well i'm getting uh some
feedback others some microphones yeah
i'm looking i'm looking to see where the
uh
where the
audience
is speaking so i'll get that muted
all right thank you thank you all right
the next thing is i can prospect
publishers
let me go back to our competitor's site
i'm going to erase all this that i just
put on
and what i see here is this
vice.com
and it's a domain of 93
and there are eight links from that
website
okay what's going on here i can go look
and see and look what's on vice
the 13 best personalized gifts for
valentine's day
so this tells me that this publisher
that they do articles that highlight
different gifts
and so now we can approach them about
their next year's valentine's list
and offer our product that what if you
highlighted our product here uh because
we know now that this publisher puts out
this type of information and we can then
approach them about utilizing our client
uh and so look to see what some of these
other links produce and
i love looking for articles where
they're doing things like this because
now it helps me make a better pitch it
helps me put together a better offer and
then it helps now this takes some media
savvy of how to approach a publisher
what's important to the publisher what
are you offering and so
this is a whole other part and this is
that strategy of how do i approach
people
not just to get the link here the link
will come
but what i'm interested in and what i
have to work for is to get them to agree
to use my clients product
and how can it help their readers how
can it help their article what can i do
to make this appealing for that writer
so now it's not just about the link it's
getting a whole story together to
present to the publisher
now also
link number six prospecting podcasters
this is where you get your ceo you get
your your programmers you get someone
who who's very knowledgeable in your
business and get them on a podcast
because guess what happens when they get
on a podcast
every podcaster puts a show page up with
links about the show
they put out social links they advertise
the podcast the bio gets published on
their website uh the name gets mentioned
and all their social posts there's
promotional content and so they get
their own page if the every podcast
guest has their own page with contact
information biography and a link back to
their site so getting on podcasts and
getting interviewed is a great way of
building additional links
now next one and and some of you may say
come on matt this is this is this is
hard yes it is because these next two
things are the hardest part of link
building because it's not link building
some of you said what you're most
interested in is content marketing
content marketing is link building
when you create amazing content guess
what
people link to it
more over 10 years ago i i wrote this
article i hate to use myself as an
example
but this was so fun it was just
absolutely amazing
i wrote an article called analytics
according to captain kirk because i'm an
old star trek fan i wrote about you know
how old star trek i i applied analytics
and analyzed the different shows and
what happened and but in doing so
explained how analytics work
this was over 10 years ago
however that page is the number one
linked to page on my website
and you can see here i have thousands of
links going to that page
number one link is a hundred domain
trust is wikipedia
wow
and then and then you know you can see
these um fandom trek initiative search
engine watch science.org
search engine watch um you can see a
couple of these i could just go down and
every few months i get new traffic
because the article gets picked up
somewhere else and and it keeps moving
i never imagined when i wrote this
article
that it would create this 10 15 years
later it was absolutely amazing what i
set out to do was to educate my audience
and teach them using a metaphor
and
that turned into amazing content and so
creating content that people love that
they're going to share with somebody
else
that creates links
content marketing is about answering
people's questions
giving them the information they need
and want and when they get it they share
it
so it's creating that content
is probably the hardest work you'll do
but the biggest benefit
that you'll have when you create that
amazing content
now here's a great example um i'm going
to pitch my publi my podcast here i did
a podcast recently with greg jarbo and
uh he is part of the simply learned
faculty as well and if you want to
listen to the podcast there's the link
but by the way what i can do in these
bitly links and this is why i love bitly
and using these links is i can put my
url oops let me get back
i can put my url in there but i can also
add these
parameters i can list what was the
source the source was a webinar
and it was part of a presentation
uh or was it a campaign and i can put
these three things in there and then
when i go look at my analytics i can see
how many people followed the link how
many people subscribed how many people
took action and so by then
using the link and using the parameters
i can now track individual links that i
use for
very specific events very specific
webinars or or any other uh you know
speaking opportunities that i have i'll
use a different link
that has tracking parameters in it so i
know the results of that
so that's one way that you can also
track the value of a link but also see
where your content goes and even bitly
will give you reports
about how many clicks and where people
were when they saw that in case people
share the bitly link
so creating amazing content i know it
might be you might say what's amazing
matt okay i'll tell you what's amazing
number one
you write an article that answers
people's questions or provides in
content in a different way
videos
video content people love video content
and when you produce something that's
entertaining when you produce something
that's a little different when you
produce something that people want to
share
that's amazing content
um now also graphics i i
i've seen this come and go with
infographics people would collect
infographics but very rarely did i see
where the infographic resulted in
additional traffic or additional visits
and increased business objectives
people liked seeing an infographic and
they appreciated it but it really seemed
to drive
action however
original research
surveys
people love that
when you create original content such as
research or surveys that gets shared
people will take the facts the data that
you share in your research and surveys
they'll put it in their articles and
they'll cite you
and that drives links
so anything that you are doing that
helps with that and in fact there's a
company out there called uh ascend to
and what they do is they offer
original research
you can work with them and they will
come up with a list of questions they'll
do surveys they create graphics and then
that brand can take that survey and they
publish it to develop
more leads but what they're also
developing is links because when that
research is published people link to it
they pull the data from it they cite
them as a source and that builds links
as well
now
probably the final method of building
link and this is probably
i won't say it's as much work as
creating content but it's work and
that's digital pr
old-fashioned public relations
now it starts with just you can build a
press release and optimize the press
release with keywords
to gain rankings
the next level is
what i showed you before i could see
that they publish articles like the best
gifts for valentine's day well i need to
put together a plan
to find out who that reporter was and
here's content that they can use in
their next article series
so i find an a publisher i find a
reporter i find a writer and i approach
them
with information that could be helpful
i'm creating content for them that they
can republish i'm making their job
easier
and i can create the original research
and then put it out on a p on a press
release that i created this and it will
get picked up
as an example a recent campaign we did
with uh digital pr
we put out a press release campaign
now the press release campaign
probably cost us
less than i would say in total less than
two thousand dollars
um to put together the information as
well as to pay for the press release uh
itself and just within the the first
week
that's the time frame for the data we
saw that the press release was viewed
over five thousand times the multimedia
view because with the press release
we included images and video
and so there was over 300 multimedia
views
we tracked because we had the
uh the tracking code in the links we saw
that it was clicked 90 times at least
and for the one week after the press
release
the press release ranked number one in
google news for our keyword
as well as ranking number one in the
google results under the top stories
it created over 200 what created 262
landing page views
which resulted in 33 leads and three
sales all in the first week of that pr
campaign
and that created a lot of links because
as people see the article they would
link to it they would talk about it and
immediately we saw a bump in the
rankings
which um within the next not only did we
get the rankings here but the rankings
have continued to grow because it
generated more and more links as well
all right i hope we have time for
question and answer here i know we got a
little bit of a late start so i'm
willing to uh stick around and make sure
i answer your questions
yes and we have uh quite a few
questions from the audience some of them
are
sort of technical
okay
[Laughter]
which is very good uh
movement share
asks
if there's a goal or a
minimum you should be looking for for
page trust
um
page trust i don't always go by that
it's just one factor
out of probably a dozen
and so that's that's a it's measurable
and they publish it
but it's a bit of a distraction so i
don't always go over that i
um
i i'm looking for reputable websites
and
reputable websites that you know maybe
they rank well they're authoritative
they're credible so i do my homework to
see if that's a good website for a link
partner um i don't just make a decision
based off page rank
okay um
that kind of
i think ties into
uh sharmila's question about
the example you used from kinstow um
if
something like that adds more links that
are not of good quality
does that improve or
detract from its page rank
um
it what the kinsa example does and let
me get back to that because that was a i
want to show
that so this is what you
kinsta published this was what they put
together
now as you can see they've got a lot of
outbound links
um you know here they're linking to a
statista page about google's revenue
so if you're creating the article
you determine where those outbound links
go how many you want um i probably would
have not put that many outbound links in
this area i think it's a little overdone
that's just my opinion
um
so but hey they're ranking well for the
primary keyword and people are linking
to them because it's a good resource so
to me it's it's the natural order of
things you're going to link out to other
sites you're going to link to other
resources and when you create good
original content people will link to you
and so you may not always see immediate
changes in rankings
but it will create that more influence
for you
so i hope that answers the question
all right
um
jim asks generally is is page rank less
important than it used to be
um
i would
well it's a debate if it was ever that
really great important uh as i said it's
one of a dozen or more factors um it's
not the only factor it's part of a a
larger calculation uh so by itself it's
not really that important it might be
just a guide but realize there there's
you know 10 12 15 more factors that are
stacked onto that we don't know
um so there are other measurements that
aren't published so um i think google at
one point even said they regretted
publishing pagerank because people
looked at that um and and we're making
decisions based off of it when they
don't even make decisions based off that
single metric
okay
um
so sarah
is
getting started in
[Music]
creating the website and doing the uh
seo and here's a couple of questions
first off
does it matter that
his
website is accessible
through secure and unsecure
http and https
does that have any impact on seo
um okay uh
well
google is
google wants https
um
and it's kind of one of those things
that i think this is why uh
programming and technical was the least
important is because
you have to change when google says
something important um so a couple years
ago google said they would they wanted
sites to be https uh they wanted that
secure layer on there and so it can make
i don't think it affects your ranking so
much as however when someone comes to
your site in the browser window it will
show that the site is not secure
and so it's more of a user experience
issue then i believe it's a rankings
issue
mark asked a question
how much time would you recommend people
spend
on
content generation
um
that depends on on your industry that
depends on if it's just you your if you
have a team
um i mean honestly anyone who wants
rankings has to become a content
creator
anyone who posts anything online has to
be a content creator so look for ways
that you can get the most out of your
content um
you know for example i've
i've got a podcast but i also
uh we we've got transcripts of the
podcast we've got audiograms of the
podcast um
what else uh
we take the podcast and we put a video
on it and put it on youtube um so there
it's we're taking the same content but
it's now being published in in like six
different ways so
in that way i'm not constantly producing
something new i'm taking what i've ex
you know created um and then there's
additional things you can do i can go
take multiple podcasts and pull clips
out of each one and create something new
um
it really depends if you're a single
business owner i know creating content
is going to be a headache because you
just want to run the business you don't
want to create content
so part of this is just looking
looking for methods of communicating to
your audience
that are most effective are you
answering people's questions
that's what it all comes down to
and you know if you're answering their
questions and you're just doing it on
twitter
you'll create a following and and
if you if you've got your audience there
and you're answering their questions
then that may be all you need to do it's
very unique to each person business
and you've got to find what works for
you
otherwise if you hate doing it you're
not going to do it
i'm going to take one last question we
are over time so i apologize for the
folks we can't get to as you can see on
the screen there's a
links for
contacting matt through
linkedin and also
his podcast
endless coffee cup
and
his
latest book teach
old dogs new tricks so um but i'm going
to take one last question
kind of between sarov and um
let me see who else has got this
uh i mean
what about link equity
in either the mobile domain or from
social media websites like
from things like pinterest that type of
thing
do those how do those rank
most links
most links in social media are nofollow
links
so if you're posting urls in instagram
you're posting urls in facebook they are
going most of the time to be nofollow um
then we can debate the value of a
nofallow link
so
what i will measure from those is how
much traffic did it generate because if
they're nofollow they're probably not
going to affect rankings much
but if they
fit a business objective and i can
measure that then they're important then
that's what i'm going to look for so
it's it's really understanding
what am i expecting when i post or
create links here
what can i expect and how can i measure
that that's what i look for
especially when i'm in social or things
like that um
you know and part of it too is
especially like instagram
uh or or i think facebook and linkedin
if you post a link in your post
you won't get as much visibility as a
post without a link
main reason is is they especially uh
facebook uh they don't want people to
leave
and so if you post a link in your post
that might make people leave and so it's
not going to get the visibility that it
would uh instagram makes it incredibly
difficult to put a link in a post they
don't want people to leave and so
they're going to make it very very hard
for you
and so there's there's some things that
way as well that you need to take into
consideration
that's
that's
an interesting insight um
so with that i'm going to go ahead and
take back the
sharing right here
and we'll close out the
the webinar with the final poll question
let me get my sharing right back here we
go got it
and
i must tell you that the the power
outage that happened here this morning
has
turned
everything on my computer to molasses
it's very
very slow
um
but again um just let you know that
matt's uh
information is here i'm going to put his
linkedin into
the
chat and you'll
be able to
see these links in the follow-up email
that
you'll receive tomorrow
which will also have a link to the
webinar recording
and
there we go
so i do want to mention
that um
you know one of the primary digital
marketing programs that simply learn
offers is in partnership with purdue
university it's a
postgraduate program in digital
marketing um it's a comprehensive
program it's
co-created
with meta blueprint which used to be
facebook blueprint
um
incorporates uh
case studies from harvard business
publishing
it's a
six-month program
that is
just about 10 hours a week
between the classes and exercises and
it features
online live virtual classrooms with
instructors
of the caliber of matt and
greg as you mentioned
it provides you with a
purdue university
postgraduate certification in mark
digital marketing
it gives you access to the alumni
association
it entails
more than 14 projects including a
capstone project that you can use as a
showpiece
to demonstrate to employers
that you've mastered
a full set of digital marketing skills
you get master classes from purdue
instructors from facebook meta
instructors
ask me anything sessions and you also um
get a separate
certification issued by meta
and it covers just a whole range of
different tools and platforms and skills
and so
i just didn't want to ask
for our audience if
a program of this type is of interest to
you
and
as we let the
computer slowly catch up to what i'm
doing
and i mean slowly
there we go
just a quick question
while we're doing that
i will
great
putting into the chat the uh
url for our
program page here
so about two-thirds of our audience is
interested in the program let me
put that url into the chat here
and
last thing i want to mention before i
say goodbye to matt is
we have a webinar happening next tuesday
in the domain of product development
so it's both for digital developers but
also product management types and and
maybe of interest of folks in marketing
but if you know of other people
that might be interested please
feel free to refer them
and ask them to
join us
and that's with a
director of technology from a
leading company
in india
and
i put that
connection
url into the chat as well
and
that
concludes the webinar i want to thank
matt very much for
this extremely
informative and engaging
session
thank you stuart i love being here and
always fun as well
okay and i also want to thank everybody
in the audience for being here with us
today we invite you to follow us on our
uh social channels
at simply learn at facebook
and
twitter simply learn on linkedin and we
hope to see you at future webinars but
we also hope to invite you into
the simply learn learning community
and with that uh
that concludes our webinar for today so
thanks everyone again
thank you
you